fue una llamada de dos horas y la
inteligencia de eeuu está preocupada
porque cree y tiene información de que
se podría dar un ataque militar de moscú
y ucrania a finales de enero del próximo
año la inteligencia militar dice que
serían hasta 105 175 mil efectivos rusos
que estarían haciendo este ataque en
múltiples frentes y precisamente frente
a esta amenaza o esta información que
tiene la inteligencia de eeuu pues lo
que están analistas preguntándose es qué
tan lejos va a ir de eeuu no solamente
con las sanciones económicas sino a
nivel militar la casa blanca dijo hoy en
el comunicado que invita a desescalar y
a volver a la diplomacia y reiteró que
tiene preparadas sanciones económicas
bastante fuertes en caso de que haya un
es cada una un ataque un avance militar
por parte de rusia hacia moscú bueno
ahora le pregunto qué es lo que pide
rusia y cuál ha sido la reacción de
ucrania a lo solicitado por bardem
la oficina de la presidencia en ucrania
dice que ve con buenos ojos el apoyo de
bailén a ucrania dice también que apoya
precisamente este mensaje de yo bailé de
desescalar y de volver a la diplomacia y
dice que no se crearon mayores
sensaciones después de esta llamada del
mandatario ruso y estadounidense vayan
por su parte y lo ha dicho ya en
repetidas ocasiones dice que eeuu no
está respetando las líneas rojas que ha
puesto a moscú esto en relación a que
ucrania entre a la otan le preocupa
mucho a moscú que ucrania siga avanzando
con sus acercamientos militares
estratégicos y la inteligencia en la
otan y eso según putin es una línea roja
como también lo es la posibilidad de que
estados unidos pues establezca un
sistema de misiles parecido al que tiene
en rumanía o en polonia o en polonia en
ucrania precisamente y esa es una de las
líneas rojas que ha mencionado de putin
y el gobierno ruso frente de cara a esta
pues a este diálogo tuvieron los dos
mandatarios sin embargo lávrov el del
secretario de asuntos extranjeros en
rusia pues dijo que a pesar de todo esto
es positivo el hecho de que haya una
llamada de que a pesar de que el
ambiente se tensó una llamada es
positivo entre los dos mandatarios